let's go to our next caller from the oh
I don't know how about the 360 row area
code caller from three six zero thanks
for holding on the line what's on your
mind today
hello yeah you're on the air
oh hi so my name is Matthew and I have a
question regarding the potential
impeachment of Donald Trump specifically
that with the current Moeller
investigation the his impeachment or at
least the indictment settled as
colleague seems inevitable or very but
at least very likely
mm-hm so you personally what would you I
guess project or speculate post in the
post impeachment White House looking
like and how that'll affect his voter
base and the next two elections in 2018
and 2020 yeah I mean your question
presumes that boat that 2018 election
which is a year away will be post
impeachment and I think that's just not
gonna happen okay yeah I mean I just
think there's absolutely even if we were
to have impeachment or more likely
resignation the I don't know if you
disagree with this Pat but I think that
there is no chance that it happens in
time for it to impact the 2018 election
I mean there are people now declaring
that there's no chance that Trump will
finish out his first term I don't know
how you can come to that conclusion I
guess it's more than likely that he will
I think he will yeah that's that's the
thing so it's very tough for me to
answer the question I mean I have said
that if there were an impeachment or
resignation that it would sort of depend
what happens next depends on is Mike
Pence so wrapped up in whatever leads to
Trump's impeachment or resignation that
he also goes or does Mike Pence become
President of the United States Pence has
been doing a pretty damn good job his
name is basically completely out of all
the Trump Russia stuff right you just
you just I mean you barely hear anything
about pence really but you just don't
really hear his name much in the last
six months in the context of the Trump
Russia investigation so I think Pence is
doing a pretty good job of keeping
himself separate from that and I think
the most likely scenario if Trump goes
is that Mike Pence becomes President of
the United States the scandal decreases
but the effectiveness of getting
geological right-wing nut job or past
goes way up that's the way I see it you
know I don't know okay um I don't know
how much time I have left but just as an
extension do so do you think we would be
better off under pence then we put it
under Trump no I've been super clear
about this I think the best scenario
given that Trump penser in the White
House already is that Trump stays
scandal-ridden ridden unable to do
anything legislatively until Democrats
take over the House and Senate in 2018
optimistically maybe 2020 and Trump
loses reelection in 2020 I think that's
the best scenario because I think Trump
out and pens in would actually be far
worse for America okay thank you all
right thank you so much appreciate the
call interesting to get a call asking
about what do you think will happen once
Trump is impeached because of Trump
Russia after a call from someone who
says there is no Trump Russia thing
going on yeah
I think this goes to the ideological
diversity of the David Pakman show
audience and for that I think we can all
be very grateful let's take a break
we'll be back after this